[Music]
pranks are fun right until they go just
a little bit too far and have terrible
consequences sometimes you might get a
bit too scared or that prank comes
completely unexpected make sure you
click that subscribe button for more
awesome stories and like this video
today we're talking about 10 pranks that
had incredible consequences saran wrap
prank let's start with the most popular
one out there saran wrap pranks they are
very simple and the most effective one
is always the toilet prank but this
woman decided to wrap up her friend who
is asleep at a birthday party well her
friend didn't exactly think her prank
was very funny after she woke up unable
to get out of her bed she reported
matters to the police and the woman was
sent to jail an unscripted magic trick
prank magic tricks are fun for this TV
shows host prank completely backfired as
part of a prank the host wanted to play
a little surprise on Wayne Halcon a
daredevil and well-known shock magician
but things weren't shopping anymore when
the host pranked him by pouring flaming
Cologne on his head and set him on fire
Wayne had serious third-degree burns and
the host faced criminal charges
Nathan fielder's funny prank challenge
this Canadian writer had a funny idea he
challenged his Twitter followers to
prank their parents for the text that
said got to Gramps for 40 bucks and then
sent another text immediately
apologizing the responses were
absolutely hilarious after this dad got
furious the kid said I didn't mean to
text you and the dad texted back I
didn't mean to have you seniors who were
serious about their parking space
this reddit user admitted that his
senior prank caused a huge traffic jam
at their school but he claims it was all
for the right reasons
the seniors played a little revenge on
the parents who wouldn't use the
students parking lot to drop off their
kids which wasn't allowed by the school
policy they decided to get up at 6 a.m.
and made a maze out of 50 cars the space
between the cars was only big enough for
one car to navigate through
and it took 15 minutes to make it to the
end point as a result many angry parents
were forced to abide the school policy
and the seniors happily watched as they
claimed back their parking lot Alabama
changed the value of pi' in 1998 the
state of Alabama played a very cruel
April Fool's prank on all mathematicians
and KY lovers they claimed that pi would
be valued at 3.0 instead of the usual
3.14159 their announcement quickly went
viral and turned into a huge protest
lever alabama the scary clown prank
clown pranks were a popular way to scare
people in 2016 but we have seen many
that have gone just a little bit too far
with many stories out there a lot of
clown pranks accidentally ended up
scaring the wrong person or the person
got scared just a little bit too much
and had an unpredictable reaction like
this thumb that ended up getting
head-butted after trying to scare people
we hoped he learned his lesson child
prank with a GoFundMe page these two
kids thought it would be funny to prank
their friend and take out his wallet but
they forgot to give it back and the
friend had to go home without his travel
card he was fine for 120 euro for riding
a train without a ticket thanks to the
two pranksters they of course had to pay
him back the money and what did they do
they set up a GoFundMe page and asked
for 120 euros this spike in a bag prank
gone wrong this polish magician was
poland's Got Talent semi-finalists and
had the opportunity to showcase his
tricks on live television he put three
bags in front of the TV presenter and
claimed one of them contained a sharp
nail but this magicians prank failed
after pressing down on the bag as
instructed the TV presenter screamed in
agony her hand was pierced by the spike
and she had to be taken to the hospital
Paris Hilton's fake plane crash prank
have you seen the video where Paris
Hilton is completely hysterical because
her plane is about to crash the Egyptian
show
Remy's in control is responsible for the
prank that left Paris in
here's and completely hysterical pretty
scary right well according to the rumors
Paris herself was in on the prank even
though she later sued the show fake or
not this prank could have gone horribly
wrong and had terrible consequences this
high school goat prank gone wrong
the Lawndale high school students
thought it would be hilarious if they've
released a dozen goats to roam free on
their football field seems like a pretty
innocent prank right little did they
know that these goats have been new
potential sources of e.coli what's made
to be a simple prank actually ended up
completely closing the football team for
six months until all bacteria is finally
removed have you ever pulled a funny
prank on someone let us know in the
comment section below and don't forget
to subscribe to our channel for more
funny fail videos check out our video on
ten people who failed hard at snapchat
[Music]